[Music]
downtown Los Angeles a new building
Rises into the city skyline
it's called Evo Evo's two-year
construction began with a hole in the
ground this is day one for the crew in
charge of but their term for concrete
the most widely used construction
material in the world before they're
finished they will pour over 47,000 tons
of it
get up the arrow there they are led by
Foreman crisp routine hey go ahead and
take me up another load make it 130 out
here on this on the our chair alone the
moment concrete is poured it begins to
harden the challenge for the 12 men
finishing crew is to make sure it
hardens with an even thickness and level
surface screaming it back pulling all
the excess of gear pulling all the
excess mud back or for the guys on the
showers will fill it back in this first
pour is highly unusual it's called a rat
slab a layer of unreinforced concrete
poured directly onto the ground its sole
purpose is to provide a smooth surface
for the first parking level deck the rat
slab is part of a process that's never
been tried before in Los Angeles called
top-down construction the idea is to
save time and money by building up and
down at the same time the 87 columns
that will support Evo have already been
embedded in the ground Construction will
now begin upwards after the first few
floors have been built 20 feet of dirt
will be excavated from underneath the
rat slab to create two additional levels
of underground parking this wall right
here will fall out and when you're
looking up it'll be like a parking
structure or you know any other kind of
building you'll be looking up in a knife
at a nice clean concrete face I guess a
theory exists you save about six months
on the scheduler something somebody
you know maybe because you're not you're
not wasting all that time going down you
can start going up right away so you'll
be going down and up at the same time
eventually waste flat I say rats lever
the waste slab but it's going to get
wasted